that's the cdc guideline and the purpose
is to mitigate further transmission of
the virus
it's not to go back and identify patient
zero i understand that's
people are very curious about that i'm
curious too that's not really what
contact tracing does
and the fact is it could be any number
of
sources i mean there were you know
journalists who wear masks a lot who
have
unfortunately contracted cobia we don't
want that to happen nobody wants that to
happen
uh there could have been any number of
guests who have been at the white house
who may be tested negative have been
later tested positive
so it's sort of an unknowable question
as to where it entered the environment
but where we go from here is trying to
mitigate further transmission
and the white house medical unit with a
cdc epidemiologist embedded in it
does contact tracing for the positive
cases that they handle the ones that
they identify with symptoms or positive
tests
um and then they go back and do that and
so positive
uh cases that have been identified by
white house medical
with the cdc uh helping them they've
completed those
and but if there are further tests that
come up positive that they handle
they'll then uh handle those as well for
people who have then
maybe they attended an event a while
back maybe nine or ten days ago here at
the white house
then they test positive nine or ten days
later their health provider or public
health officials who are handling that
positive test but then do that 48 hour
look back
on that contact tracing let me ask you
by the president if i can very quickly
it's approaching 48 hours since we've
seen him in public either photos you
guys provide or on
video will we see them in any form why
haven't we seen him at that time given
the fact that you guys have the ability
even without anybody present to provide
us images
i he he wants to to speak to the
american people he will do so
soon i don't have an exact time or a def
or a definite way he'll do that as
you've seen there have been twitter
videos
that are a pretty easy and effective way
for him to get out
you know that's certainly something that
we're always considering
as putting out another message to the
country that way but i don't have a
definite
method or time for you at this time
brian can you tell us about
sorry sure who uh the president's been
spending time with today what advisors
are with him
um and i know he said we don't know
when we might see him but has he shot
any of those videos today or yesterday
anything like that
how has he spent his time i i know
they've worked on one
uh he's spoken he speaks regularly
with the chief and a number of his
senior advisors
dan scavino we all know of course he
speaks with members on the hill leaders
on the hill
he wants to make sure that our
outstanding nominee for the supreme
court that her nomination is
proceeding expeditiously fairly and
thoroughly
but i won't get into any particular
private conversations but suffice it to
say he's speaking with a number of
senior advisors
and uh and leaders on the hill as well
and is it true that preparations are
underway for
him to potentially go work out at the
oval office anytime soon
so uh we have uh
ways for him to do that we have ppe that
we can use
and we can interact with him standing
back like you're standing back from
me and uh people can wear masks or
goggles or gloves or whatever may be
needed we have cdc guidelines
so uh when he's ready and and the white
house and the west wing are deep cleaned
on a regular basis
so there's a way for him to work out of
a variety of rooms safely when he's
ready to do that
i think we saw today in the doctor's
announcement that
he's symptom-free uh that there's
antibodies
that they're identifying now it's a
great sign are they here
that uh good question i'll have to ask a
doctor that actually but
i i i think it's they supplement what
your body
creates i believe but that's really a
question for dr conley so i i won't
speculate bring doctor
he was not in the oval office yesterday
there were precautions set up
uh so that he can do that over the
coming days when he's ready to do that
but he was not in the oval yesterday are
we gonna know
when he was last tested negative or is
that just gonna
so i think we put out the information
that that we've got on that that you
know
uh hope had heard positive tests
thursday the president announced his
positive test very late thursday very
promptly
um right and and that's uh the kind of
timeline that that we've got at this
point
why can't the white house say when he's
not there
look we've addressed this they we're not
asking
to go back through a bunch of records
and look backwards we're looking
the contact racing process is to
mitigate further spread of the disease
that's kind of the
the posture we take so yeah did you have
uh
yeah are we gonna get another briefing
from dr conley dr connolly put out his
latest assessment
in writing uh we kind of make are making
these decisions
you know day by day sort of um
just as things go along we assess
circumstances and then determine the
best way to communicate
why his vitals are not provided
uh i can look into that but i
i mean suffice it to say the president's
own words he's feeling great
he's symptom-free uh and you know we
hope to have him
uh able to be back interacting uh
in person as soon as possible as soon as
it's safe uh
it's you know great news that he's now
symptom-free for a
fairly long period of time no fever uh
and he's feeling well and we're glad to
have him back at the white house
thank you explain just one for a minute
just one for me before you go
can you just
it that wouldn't compromise anyone
um and i i think
you may know from past research and dr
pepper experts you know
we're getting to a place where he
wouldn't be affected with the davis
anymore
that's a good thing certainly uh the
doctors are monitoring that we don't
want
anyone he can interact with us in the
same way
that's a great thing he's continuing to
work hard for the american people and
he's not going to stop doing that
is anybody covering the uh the russia
gate stuff that's coming out of
modi and it's a fantastic story it's
really fascinating not fantastic but
the fact that uh the clinton campaign
was actually driving the russia hoax
is a very important story so i'd
recommend everybody look into it
and cover that
he was tested very regularly as we're
the senior staff who interact with him
on a regular basis
i think
i should have directed